[Musique]
on parle de plus en plus méditation
aujourd'hui avec les idées reçues
comme quoi il faut faire le vide ne plus
avoir de penser être complètement
immobile il faut prendre le temps de
voir se poser toutes ces idées reçues
plus le fait qu' on est dans une société
occidentale où le mental est très
présent le rythme de vie est très
intense
du coup on peut avoir peur sans compter
sur la fameuse première fois cette
première méditation où on se dit plein
de bonne volonté
allez j'y vais je m'assois je dis à mon
mental ne pense plus je dis à mon corps
ne bouge plus et leur bout de quelques
secondes
qu'est-ce qui se passe mon corps s'agite
mon et commence à gratter
mes pensées commencent à se démultiplier
part dans tous les sens je m'agace et je
me dis stop ce n'est pas pour moi et
cela est fort dommage fort dommage de se
priver de cet outil merveilleux de la
méditation qui permet justement une
ouverture à soi ce que je vous propose
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller voir une
nouvelle vision de la mutation dans ce
cas les comme art de vivre l'art de
vivre c'est l'art d'être présent à soi
l'art d'être justement dans cette
présence de ce mouvement de vie en nous
et non pas dans l'immobilisme l'art de
vivre c'est devenir l'artiste de sa vie
c'est justement aller voir ce mouvement
de vie qui se joue en nous qui remuent
qui bouge et non pas être technicien de
sa vie le technicien qui applique
simplement des concepts des concepts
tout fait je dois il faut qu'ils restent
dans le mental et qui ne redescend pas
là dans le corps dans le coeur
aujourd'hui je vous propose d'aller
regarder ce mouvement vous d'aller voir
ce merveilleux cette énergie de vie qui
à chacun de nous pendant la méditation j
vous demandez à un moment donné de poser
votre main gauche sur votre voisin sur
l'épaule de droite de votre voisin pour
ceux qui sont en bout de rangée bien sûr
ce sera à votre voisin de gauche qui
posera sa main droite sur votre épaule
si vous demandez de vous lever pour ceux
qui le peuvent ce qu'ils ont envie
peuvent enlever ses choix leurs
chaussures
si vous le souhaitez moi je vois pas
bien en fait c'est pour ça ok donc déjà
là juste observer ce qui se passe en
vous d'être simplement debout les yeux
ouverts
observez comment ça bouge à l'intérieur
est ce que vous êtes à l'aise mal à
l'aise est-ce que vous posez la question
de caisse qu'elle est en train de me
faire faire et fermer les yeux fermés
les yeux et venait justement observer ce
qui se passe dans ce retrait du monde
extérieur pour mieux venir juste là à
l'intérieur de vous
observez comment se ressent votre corps
là maintenant est-ce qu'il est stable ou
est-ce qu au contraire il vacille est-ce
que c'est agréable d'avoir les yeux
fermés et simplement prendre le temps
également laissé passer toutes vos
pensées
les scellés tranquillement des filets ne
cherchez pas à les arrêter juste laisser
aller prendre le temps de venir pors
porter votre attention au niveau de
votre respiration à la ressentez ce
mouvement de la respiration ressentez ce
mouvement de vie qui est en vous ce
mouvement de vie qui est là depuis le
tout début
depuis votre tout premier souffle cette
source
illimité d'apaisement et de réconfort
juste en prendre conscience
dans ce mouvement de vie le laisser tout
simplement descendre le long de votre
corps venir dans vos jambes dans vos
pieds et là au niveau de vos pieds ce
mouvement de vie vient se connecter à
l'énergie de la terre mère une énergie
qui vient stabiliser sécuriser une
énergie de douceur d'amour qui vient
tout simplement amplifier votre
mouvement de vie et vous stabiliser un
peu plus comme si vos pieds s'ancrer
encore un peu plus dans le sol
laissez ce mouvement de vie avec
l'énergie de la terre mère se diffuser
en vous et venir poser vos demain sur
votre coeur allard santé le battement de
votre coeur
ressentez
ce rythme
cette pulsion d'amour qui est en vous
ressentez tout cet amour qui hélas
s'être connexion à votre puissance
personnelle à ce merveilleux qui est en
vous laissez venir à vous glisser des
souvenirs agréables des souvenirs de
joie des rires laisser tout cela dit
fier de plus en plus ici connecter à
votre puissance personnelle reconnecter
vous à l'innocence à la joie au reer est
la tendresse à la douceur et laissez vos
mains se remplir de tout cela et prend
le temps maintenant de poser votre main
sur l'épaule de votre voisin ce
merveilleux voisin qui est à côté de
vous
ressentez cette main posée sur votre
épaule santé sa douceur peut être sa
fermeté peut-être est-ce une meuf
familière 7 ce ressenti que vous
connaissez déjà qui vient dans notre
espace temps peut-être s est mainteant
attendu qui hélas ici maintenant
cette main qui vous dit et confiance je
suis fier de toi et confiance je suis là
je t'accompagne et confiance laisse
venir à toi tout ce qui vibre tout ce
merveilleux
nous sommes là nous accompagnons et
confiant parce qu'il ya juste là au plus
profond de toi aux ce premier pas aux ce
choix pose
tu es guider soit rassuré
laissez venir à vous tous que cette main
à vous transmettre
tout l'amour la tendresse le soutien la
fierté
simplement laisser tout cela suffisait
de plus en plus à l'intérieur
de plus en plus profondément
prendre le temps d'observer ce mouvement
qui grandit un peu plus
dans ce mouvement de vie prendre le
temps également de retrouver le
mouvement de votre respiration
le mouvement de la respiration qui vient
vous ramener ici et maintenant dans
votre corporalité pour amener ici et
maintenant vous allez vous redirigez ici
dans la salle revenir tranquillement
complètement conscient ouvrir les yeux
accueillir ce qu'il se passe à
l'intérieur
s'il ya eu des sensations ou signares ya
eu du tout tout est juste tout est ok
pour vous rasseoir
bien sûr il peut y avoir des émotions
qu'on laisse faire on laisse venir la
méditation ça peut être ça il n'y a pas
de règles il n'y a pas de norme en fait
la méditation c'est cet art de vivre
cette terre des trois dans la présence à
soi c'est osé révéler cet artiste qui
entend vous osez vous reconnecter à ce
mouvement de vie on vous sait simplement
aller rechercher vos besoins elle est
recherchée vraiment ce qui vibre en vous
et ce qui est le meilleur pour vous que
ce soit de méditer dans un cadre bien
spécifique que ce soit se balader dans
la nature et profiter de l'énergie de la
nature que ce soit dans la contemplation
ou simplement dans les petits gestes du
quotidien
simplement être dans cette conscience de
tout ce qui bouge en vous être dans la
conscience que ce mouvement de vie vous
anime être tout simplement l écoute de
soi
soyez l'artiste de votre vie merci
[Applaudissements]